one of the biggest challenges and the
visual effects and you see when you work
a future movie everybody in the last
three months the vendor power so in your
situation let's say you get everybody to
go online and then everybody suddenly
needs render power these last two three
months what is your capacity where your
limits or is it is it possible that I
end up in a situation where it's like oh
sorry you have to wait a week or so
before we can give you render notes so
at this point I turn around and tell you
that we have unlimited compute power but
will you have it because now you don't
have that you don't have the market
because I can tell you from firsthand
experience most studious they go and
rent rent rent Rendon olds and I had it
where I went to the render node company
I said what's going on everybody wants
random notes what show are you working
on and we were all working on 2012 movie
and and we couldn't get random notes and
it got even to the point where I
couldn't buy CPUs because of them all
the vendors were like no we have to wait
two months now all the CPUs are sold out
I'm absolutely with you on that I worked
on a show where we we were in Sydney and
we ended up having to get the avatar
render farm and put it in a container
and float it across to Sydney and then
hook it up at the docks in order to
finish our show so I totally understand
the scarcity resource in that regard
what I can say is that google buys about
nineteen percent of the like just under
twenty percent of the global intel
production it's just crazy how many
cores there are and there the the fact
that we had this planetary network and
we and also the fact that we have data
centers in multiple locations in the
planet we have customers who are
rendering in Iowa for instance in
Central us who were in Asia because it
slightly less expensive for them to
render there and once you get past the
whole file system in the cloud and
sinking your asset issue you can render
anywhere on the planet so we are much
less susceptible to localization issues
as far as you know it is a hot as a huge
amount of rendering required an A or B
also because of our clients are
diversified across a whole bunch of
verticals so although the the visual
effects industry is going to have the
summer blockbuster and the Thanksgiving
push and you know all of the little
bumps or commercial divisions are going
to have the super bowl those are quite
small workloads compared to the
planetary compute resource that Google
has so although I can't promise
truly unlimited cores if you get in
touch with us like a few days in advance
capacity planning can move things around
to a significant level there's data
loads that can be moved from one data
center to another if you need 10,000
cores on Wednesday and it's Monday talk
to us and concessions can be made I'll
hand the mic down just in case the one
other thing I would add from a Google
point of view is we would relish the
opportunity to to try to break us no s
Jeff points out we have a lot of cores
available question Becker yeah i get i
was going to say that the other big
problem Jerry and render pushes is the
everyone sleeping under the desk and the
the office gets really really dark and
funky and everyone smells I yeah that
yeah that's the other limiting factor
lack of schwag tisha so you can change
into yeah I guess the other one the
thing too for production people is in
the in the fields and foreign the
jungles of Costa Rica or anywhere that
maybe we might not have connectivity to
the cloud what kind of offerings are do
you guys know of anything kind of a
queuing system where hey I can be with
no connectivity do my job almost a
script like you know without being a
programmer myself once i get
connectivity everything is going up to
the cloud and computing and everything
else i don't know if that makes sense
but it's one of the things that we deal
with on a you know regular basis where
we don't have connectivity like South
Africa for example you know when we've
been there working and we want to work
within the cloud is there any kind of
queueing model that is coming up I guess
you know in the future of offline I'll
pick that up really quickly and say we
don't have a specific offering for you
know the middle of Africa on set for
however if you look at technologies like
the Loon project where we have you know
big hydrogen balloons flying around the
planet providing connectivity and we
also have an aerospace division that
we've announced that has you know giant
flying airplanes and other cool
technology like that you can google that
up and find out more but the point is
the possibility of providing
connectivity anywhere on the planet is
in the future hope we are today we are
partnering with companies like an
you know suggest Iron Mountain being
local here in Los Angeles where you can
potentially take a you know attach each
blue arc in the back of a truck and plug
it in with fortigate pipes and upload to
the cloud and not have to burden your
own system so happy to talk with you
further about you know possible ideas
you have as far as how to make that go
but beyond the global wireless goodness
and a pickup truck that's those are kind
of our two options right now anyone else
want to pick that up yes hi I'm your
left from storage engineer at Google so
the cool thing about google is we have a
very large global network with more into
connection points than any other network
provider on the planet and we actually
have connectivity to South Africa as
well that's one of the peering points
yeah and so one of the cool things about
the Google platform a google cloud
platform is that once your network
packet comes from your facility through
some isp typically directly to google
then you get a high speed you know
first-class ticket straight to our data
centers so you know the reason we run
our global fiber backbone is because we
want to control high-traffic runs we run
the trail it's a software-defined
Network that's heavily optimized for
client traffic so there's basically full
utilization with no congestion for your
traffic right so as soon as you make to
the Google connection points then you go
straight to our data centers in our
network so that's the best we can offer
think one of the things that we're doing
for our customers is offering them a
additional piece of software allows them
to ingest content into the cloud
environment and automatically adjust to
do networking condition something to
putting simply give you an example is if
the average video feed runs at six
megabits per second and your bandwidth
on to one megabit per second will
automatically additionally compress that
add a little bit of additionally latency
on top of that just to make sure we can
get all the bits and will reorder the
pockets and everything else make sure
that a duel and inside a cloud
environment until either better
connectivity becomes available or
there's ability to peer directly into
the Google Network
you guys mention about the mpaa
certification and as a second half of
2015 how realistic is that because you
know a small studio they would like to
get bigger projects and count when the
cloud with a cloud platform for that if
these Studios don't want allow you to
use it that's a big problem because so
basically we cannot do it so there's two
pieces to that one is right now we're
we're waiting on the mpaa we're waiting
for their revised best practices
document I'm pretty confident that we
can meet or exceed the requirements that
are in that document so my challenge
becomes how do I convey that to the
industry and so this is a little bit of
what we'd like to help facilitate what
the industry is how do you want to
verify this how do you who do you want
to trust in terms of yes this these are
these these security controls at this
vendor our meeting this requirement in
the specification is it going to be a
self-certified process or do we want to
you know are we going to use the big
five auditing firms you know we'd like
to help facilitate that conversation so
that we can do it in a standard fashion
and it makes sense so the realistic
timeline on being able to you know I you
know I can I as soon as I get my hand on
that speck I can answer it pretty
quickly I have all the evidence and
based upon what I believe is in there I
think we have good answers to those
questions whether you believe me or not
that's another thing but I've got no
reason to not tell you the truth I mean
I want your business I don't want to I
don't want to you know I don't want to
trick you so no no but it but I my
concern is young it's not just google it
it's the boy direction with the NPA yeah
so so the hope is that our hope is is
that that the industry embrace
is that as a standard in it and it works
for them short of that the other thing
that we're doing is we're also engaged
in conversations with the major studios
and talking to them about the unique
requirements they might have as a
different company or how we can work
with them to satisfy answering their
questions they may have an independent
auditor that they'd like us to talk to
and work with we've had some discussions
on along those lines they may want to do
some auditing themselves we're having
some discussions along those lines so
we're were we're trying to navigate that
and we're trying to do it as quickly as
we can so that it's not a barrier I wish
I could tell you like yep December 15th
will be done I don't want to make that
commitment to you but what I will commit
to is that this is important to us and
we are watching it very very closely and
we're doing I think everything that we
can do to make sure that we're you know
making progress there is I think that's
probably the best answer I could give
you so I'll step in I was part of the
team that helped craft that stuff and
hand it off to the NPA so if you want to
get an advance look at some of that
stuff or be ready for it when it comes
out I would look at the CSA the cloud
security alliance which helped craft the
document and ISE which is the lead
auditor for Marvel and the Disney groups
which helped also drive this so those
two organizations will be the best one
to get in a dance view yes si si ni SE
hi my name is eric weaver i work with
the ET c so we helped drive some of
those standards and changes so thanks
additional questions questions questions
I think it's time then Thank please
thank all of our panelists Oliver
speakers good job guys